les spécialistes de la santé viennent de
tracer les grandes lignes d'un domaine
encore mal définie l'alimentation de
l'enfant d'âge scolaire
si les enfants mangent suffisamment leur
alimentation pèchent souvent par manque
de pain et par abus de sucreries et de
viande
des erreurs qui peuvent entraîner à long
terme des maladies comme
l'artériosclérose ou encore l'obésité
autre aspect important le rapport entre
les repas servis dans les restaurants
scolaires et les développement psychique
et intellectuel de l'enfant
les spécialistes proposent d'améliorer
la composition et la confection des
repas scolaires ainsi qu'une meilleure
détente de l'après repas car il faut
bien reconnaître que tout ne va pas pour
le mieux dans les cantines scolaires
san matinée à l'école après les
additions et des soustractions c'est
l'heure de l'opération repas qui comme
chacun sait doit être un moment de
détente de répit alors écoutez
[Musique]
le menu est toujours une surprise qui
est chargé de la composition des menus
vis c'est moi même qui en fixe ce choix
madame g par exemple aujourd'hui décidé
la pollution suivant les maquereaux
comme entrer ensuite du poulet rôti avec
des petits pois les carottes sais pas si
c'est ok parce que permanent ils sont
revenus dans les carottes un gâteau de
riz aux yeux qu'il était donné comme
dessert et croyez vous que les enfants
sont satisfaits même la plupart oui
pourquoi
non pas six mois
bon
et toi trouve que c'est bon
ne vous fait pas qu'est ce que vous
faites moi j'ai pas du tout
c'est
obliger ses réflexions désabusées
on les doit au fait que le directeur ne
peut en réalité tenir compte des désirs
des enfants il ne décide pas vraiment du
menu puisqu'il est dépendant des achats
en gros des livraisons qui lui sont
faites chaque jour par l'oeuvre des
cantines de la ville
conséquence principale c'est plus une
question d' équilibre budgétaire que d'
équilibre alimentaire qui guide ses
choix c'est pourquoi malgré un matériel
pédagogique mis à la disposition des
enseignants les enfants encore une
notion très vague de ce qu'il faut
manger pour être en bonne santé
qu'est ce que tu as vraiment g
est-ce que manger pour être un buggy
whip it war
haïti libre et quoi
et chaque jour au bout de trois quarts
d'heure quatre millions d'enfants pressé
retrouve dans le calme de leur classe un
autre genre de casse tête
mais cette fois sur leur ardoise
[Musique]